so abortions have been legal in the
united states for nearly 50 years but
that could all be changing the us
supreme court could be about to overturn
the nationwide legal right to abortion
an early draft of a coming supreme court
decision leaked to the public late
yesterday suggest that by this summer a
majority of the justices will overturn
roe versus wade
that we are not going away
[Music]
so
how many people get an abortion it's
actually not as easy to find these
numbers as you would think
so the federal government through the
cdc
has an abortion surveillance program and
they estimate that in 2019 there are
around 630 000 abortions in the united
states but the thing about the federal
numbers is that providers voluntarily
submit data to states which means the
data set is incomplete and the data set
excludes states like california maryland
and new hampshire so the actual number
is likely far higher
other groups like the guttmacher
institute which is a
reproductive rights research and policy
organization have created model-based
approaches and so based on their models
they put that number much higher at
around 886 000 abortions per year in the
united states
there is no contraceptive method that is
a hundred percent effective in
preventing pregnancy
now
there are surgical methods like
vasectomies or tubal ligations but i was
actually surprised to learn that even
these can have a fraction of a percent
of a failure rate which means that
someone could still get pregnant then
you have long-acting contraceptive
methods like iuds or implants and so
those have less than a one percent
chance of failure and then you move up
to
things like the pill
or the patch or the ring
and those have around a 7 failure rate
and then if you depend on say just a
condom there's a 13 failure rate for
that and for withdrawal
it's even higher 20 failure rate
[Music]
when we talk about abortion there are
two different options there's medication
abortion or surgical abortion
medication abortion is what's commonly
referred to as the abortion pill but
it's actually a combination of two pills
that someone needs to take
we are starting to see a rise in the
number of medication abortions so for
the first time in 2020 the guttmacher
institute estimated that medication
abortions account for 54
of abortion so this is the first time
ever that that passed the 50 threshold
which is up from 39 in 2017 which is the
last time that they surveyed all
abortion providers in the us
the average pregnancy lasts around 40
weeks and is split into three trimesters
the vast majority of abortions occur in
the first trimester so 93
occur before 13 weeks of gestation
what's happened recently is states are
passing bans at different weeks so texas
oklahoma and idaho have all recently
passed bans on abortion after six weeks
when we look at some of the polling
numbers an april wall street journal
poll
found that 48 of us adults somewhat
support restricting abortion but that's
after 15 weeks of pregnancy
well 43 oppose it
for an abortion in the first trimester
of pregnancy there are two options
medication abortion or surgical abortion
and they're both around the same costs
the median cost for a medication
abortion in 2020 was around 560 dollars
and for first trimester surgical
abortion was
575 dollars
if you get an abortion in the second
trimester the price goes up so then your
option is a surgical abortion and the
median cost was around 895 dollars
these are out of pocket costs if you
don't have insurance
and to put this in context around 12
percent of u.s households would be
unable to pay a 400 emergency expense in
either case first trimester or second
trimester and out of pocket abortion
would be more than that the other
important thing to note is that the
percentage of providers that are
accepting insurance for abortion
procedures are going down from around 89
in 2017 to 80
in 2020.
when it comes to costs it isn't just the
medication or the procedure
what's increasingly happening as
different states past restrictions is
people are having to travel longer and
longer
[Music]
distances the bridget alliance which is
a new york-based non-profit that
arranges travel for people seeking
abortions says the average cost is
around a thousand dollars and so that
includes transportation hotels
child care reimbursement and meal
stipends
we don't know for sure what will happen
with the supreme court's opinion on roe
vs wade until the final opinion comes
out sometime in june or july of this
year but what we do know is that if
abortion is kicked to the state level
and there becomes this patchwork system
it just means that accessing abortion is
going to become
more expensive and more difficult
because people are going to have to
travel greater distances and it also
means that some people might not be able
to access abortions at all
you